what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting back into the Thanos
solo series Jeff Lemire is a writer is
crazy this was proven to be like one of
the coolest series that's out there
nathanael solo series in a lot of ways
really kind of wraps up these loose ends
that were sort of left hanging by
Jonathan Hickman and Avengers the New
Avengers going into secret Wars in the
sense that it basically wrapped up the
character of Fame now Fame in a lot of
ways was just sort of introduced in
Marvel Comics by Jonathan Hickman and
we'll talk about that as we go through
our run on Avengers and New Avengers but
he was brought in as a reason for that
us to invade Earth he was basically
looking for his son now it led to a
great big huge conflict different things
like that and Thane himself continued on
as a character who was just sort of in
the background and was there the problem
is that Marvel never really knew what to
do with him now again as far as we're
aware this all should have been wrapped
up in Secret Wars because that story
basically sets the stage for just a line
wide reboot the issue is that you know
from a lot of speculation mom will kind
of got cold feet and the result is that
they backed off the idea of a reboot and
just kind of continued on and so what it
did is it took all these plot threads it
should have been wrapped up in Secret
Wars and it just kind of left them
lingering so really it was just all
these different concepts that were just
sort of there for the character of Thane
what Jeff Lemire did was actually really
really cool because Thane was the son of
Thanos and because he was sort of I
guess living among the Inhumans what we
ended up finding out was that Thane was
basically being manipulated by mistress
death and again mistress death has a
long-standing in Marvel Comics for a
variety of reasons one because she is
the tried and true version of death but
her manipulations behind-the-scenes with
regards to Thanos and Thanos constantly
chasing after her affections has been a
long-standing part of this publication
history I'd go so far as to say it's a
cornerstone of the Thanos character with
mistress death chasing after the son of
Thanos basically going after Thane what
this did is a set in motion the idea the
Thane basically sought after the Phoenix
force and so what this man is that he
basically took the Phoenix egg which is
to say this sort of representation of
what the Phoenix force will become
absorbing that energy unto himself and
becoming the new avatar for the Phoenix
and what that means is that he has nya
on nitin power and one of the first ways
in which he demonstrated this power was
stripping Thanos of all the abilities he
had and even his immortality and making
him mortal and virtually powerless and
so that's where this picks up you know
where Thanos has basically cast back to
Titan he was sent back to his home
planet with no real power
himself it's him basically fighting for
survival and that's the cool thing here
and this is what I love so much about
the character of Thanos under normal
circumstances when you have a character
in comics who has all these different
powers and all these different abilities
and they're basically all stripped away
usually it's kind of like oh man what am
I gonna do now and they just kind of
give up and they're just kind of moping
around and they're just kind of like
whatever with Thanos it's not that way
Thanos was a madman and he was a Titan
and every ounce of the word from the
time he was a kid till he first lost his
powers here he's always had a strong
understanding of who he is and what he
was about a lot of that was the results
of experimentation but this is designed
to say vanos has no powers Thanos is
mortal but it doesn't mean that Thanos
is a weakling he's just as dangerous as
he ever was because despite the fact
that Thames took away everything that
makes Thanos who he is in terms of
powers and immortality the one thing he
couldn't take away is Stannis his mind
his ingenuity the fact that he's one of
the smartest people out there in the
Marvel Universe but it's also designed
to sort of humanize Thanos a little bit
because where he's ready to deal with
some of the most capable people who are
out there and overcome almost any
challenge he can face when it goes to
doing something like creating fire it's
difficult for him to pull off he's not
able to do it readily and it's almost
kind of crushing for him because now he
has to deal with the harsh realities of
the cold it's basically rebuilding him
again it's all rooted in the idea that
Thanos is doing the best he can trying
to keep himself going now of course this
also coincides with the arrival of Star
Fox nebula and the champion of the
universe now when it comes to these
characters they have all played pretty
significant roles throughout their time
and this is something that I want to
clarify when it comes to the Infinity
stones one of the things that I've seen
recently when people are talking about
the Infinity stones I saw it on like the
Marvel Studios subreddit and I saw it on
the main reddit page there and things
like that people were talking about the
Power Stone and whoa we'll connect these
dots here in a second so I'm not going
off on a tangent for no reason but
people talk about the power stone and
they say the Power Stone is basically
this thing that you know makes people
physically stronger that's not true the
Power Stone amplifies whatever power
people have in the case of of champion
of the universe he was a character that
resided on physical strength and so the
Power Stone amplified his physical
strength if you gave the power stone of
Charles Xavier it would amplify his
telepathy if you gave it to Franklin
Richards it would amplify his
reality-warping powers it amplifies the
existing
powers over whoever's possessing it
that's why it's so important when it
comes to the Infinity Gauntlet because
each of the Infinity stones outside of
the Power Stone have abilities the soul
stone basically allows you to sort of
analyze and capture the souls of people
mind stone allows you to you know expand
the mind and control dominate the minds
of others read the mind of others what
the power stone does is it comes along
and amps up all the powers of those
stones and then basically allows it
allows the self to function as a bedrock
meaning because it's an infinite source
of power the stones can in turn draw on
the power stone and never run out of
energy so that's really kind of how that
works but in Thanos quest the big moment
really one of the biggest moments of the
champion of the universe is that he
basically gained the power stone and
what I did is I set him on his crusade
to basically you know trying to find a
challenger of course Thanos showed up
tricked him out of the Power Stone but
that was the whole idea of a champion of
the universe that's really where he
comes from for the character of Star Fox
he is basically the brother of tano's
the next one of these of course is
nebula now nebula was interesting
because for years she masqueraded as the
daughter or granddaughter of fan o's
only for him to basically find out she
was lying that's why if you go and you
read the Infinity Gauntlet story she's
all twisted and screwed up and weird
looking because Thanos had basically
warped her mind using the Infinity
Gauntlet in addition to other forms of
torture and so on now of course that
leads him to the conclusion of the
Infinity Gauntlet and most likely the in
conclusion of the infinity war storyline
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
it's still interesting these guys have
all in some form or fashion dealt with
Thanos and in a lot of ways they hate
phantoms with them having basically been
shanghaied and tricked by Fame into
helping him game the Phoenix force and
then in turn abandon they now turn to
Thanos as a way to basically stop his
son now keep in mind each of these
characters are people who have explored
the universe in a variety of ways so I
mean they're well aware of the threat
the Thane poses in possession of the
Phoenix force status of course having
battled his own son and lost his powers
in the process they basically come
together because they have to now when
the question is asked what they should
do what the answer should be
Thanos immediately says we have to chart
a course to the furthest reaches of the
universe we have to go as far out as we
possibly can and the reason for this is
because what they're doing is they're
tracking down something called the god
quarry
now this is one of the other reasons why
I love Jeff Lemire is writing so much is
because when it comes to things like the
god quarry he basically makes this up
the god quarry exists at the farthest
reaches of the universe and the only way
to access it it's actually travel
through a gravity well the whole idea
here is that run arriving here at the
god quarry this is basically where gods
go to die and it's really really cool
because we've seen this done in a
variety of different ways in Marvel
Comics for example if we reference Jason
Aaron's Thor god of thunder we learned
about Gore the god butcher and we
learned about like the Congress of
Worlds and we learned about things like
this massive pantheon of gods in the
sense that within the Marvel Universe
there's all kinds of gods out there what
this does is it builds on that and it
says there's actually a place where gods
go to die and they'll go there for any
number of reasons they'll go there
because of the fact that people don't
worship them anymore they'll go there
because they've just kind of evolved to
a new state whatever the case is when
they come to the god quarry it's
basically a test of sorts these three
witches this coven has supposedly
existed before anything else before any
other God existed but this whole idea
this trial of the god quarry is that if
a person goes into the quarry they
essentially undergo a trial and what
this trial means is that they will begin
the process of basically experiencing
kind of an illusion of sorts you know
this quote-unquote nightmare so to speak
depending on what it is that they're
doing if they're strong in self if they
know who they are then they'll
immediately just walk out unscathed and
basically receive the power of the god
quarry if they fail they're confined to
the god quarry forever and that's what
you see with all these different statues
opposed it in place
these are gods who failed the test and
basically their souls are fed upon by
this coven now one other thing to keep
in mind here is that Thane is still kind
of in the background he's still being
manipulated by mistress death and it's
basically this idea that because she is
a cosmic entity and because she has
cosmic awareness on everything that's
going on her response is your father is
trying to make his return you have to go
there you have to stop him you have to
kill Thanos and take his place and stand
at my side and you know that kind of
thing basically the same manipulations
in the same form of ensnaring that we
saw her pull when it came to Thanos
himself now with Thanos submitting
himself to the god quarry he immediately
begins a process of undergoing this
trial so to speak and what this does is
it basically shows us that Thanos
essentially experiences this kind of
scenario where he fights alongside the
Avengers and that's what's so cool here
is because we're not given this
transition he's just there he's just
fighting alongside the
he's leading the Avengers team vision
Ironman Miss Marvel daredevil he's there
fighting alongside all of them one of
the things to keep in mind is that with
Thanos he's well aware of earth
he knows about all the superheroes it's
interesting because as Thanos goes
through this he realizes something isn't
right here this is not how things are
supposed to be that none of this is real
and that scenario is presented in terms
of the foes that a nose has faced the
people that he's defeated over the years
received things like Adam warlock
there's the image of Thanos getting the
Infinity Gauntlet this basically just
sort of asked the question what would
what would happen if Thanos became a
good guy ultimately he says this isn't
right none of this is real
and he basically regains his bearings
realizing he's Thanos he's just as
villainous as he ever was but his powers
began to sort of emerge here as he's
going through the solution and what this
means is he's receiving the power of the
god quarry now because of the fact that
this is so ambiguous in terms of what
the power of the god quarry is what this
seems to indicate is that all if Thanos
his power returns to him he gets all his
powers back the way he was before
presumably even before the events of
secret Wars so it's basically classic
Thanos with all the powers of classic
Thanos what this means for those of you
guys who are not familiar with this
character it means a nose is godly now
it means he's crazy powerful so of
course what this means is that with
Thane having shown up in this realm of
the coven where the intention of facing
off against his father it's amazing
because is essentially Thane with the
Phoenix force fighting against classic
Thanos and this is classic Marvel
storytelling that's what this is and
that's why this is so cool if you go and
you read the old Pharaoh's comics for
the most part that's the kind of thing
you saw but the long and short in terms
of what we're given here and what we're
being shown here is that Thanos is
easily able to stand against the
entirety of the Phoenix force and for a
lot of classic Marvel readers this is
going to raise some eyebrows and to a
degree they're kind of right I mean when
it comes to the Phoenix force you got to
remember the Phoenix forces power is
almost infinite as long as the
multiverse exist as long as like the
Marvel Universe exists essentially the
Phoenix force will always exist and
it'll always be nigh omnipotent and
that's kind of the funny thing here is
because classic Thanos was extremely
capable in terms of its power and so
while it is kind of difficult to grasp
this is one of those scenarios of an
unstoppable force meeting an immovable
object but the reason why Thanos ends up
coming out on top of this is because his
son is inexperienced and that's really
what's being hit on here Thanos has
wrestled
absolute power on a multitude of
occasions the first time he got the
Infinity stones he turned him into one
giant stone and tried to blink out all
the stars in the universe the second
time he got the Infinity stones he
basically had the Infinity Gauntlet he's
had the Cosmic Cube if you believe that
Marvel the end is in continuity which
technically it's not he's had the heart
of the universe basically the power of
the one above all he's fought Galactus
to a standstill
I mean he's routinely had absolute power
he's routinely been one of these guys
who has gained just these insane levels
of power and so having done that time
and time again he's become the wiser
because of it he's learned his
limitations Thane is basically a young
kid who has no idea the power he
possesses in the form of the Phoenix
force or how to even use it because of
the fact that he's so inexperienced with
all this power that he has which could
easily be translated into any form of
reality warping if you pushed it to the
extreme limit instead all the Phoenix
force becomes for him is a way to just
make himself physically stronger and
punch harder it's just a very basic
premise a very basic way of fighting and
so were the two of them end up engaging
in their own battle this of course leads
directly into the god quarry and so of
course what Danis does and facing off
against his son is basically begin to
bring up all these different points not
only that because of the fact that he
basically captured the Phoenix force
unwillingly the Phoenix force
effectively abandons him the coven comes
along and simply says the Phoenix force
is not supposed to be here the Phoenix
force has no business here and they in
turn banished it from the god quarry now
I want you to think about that for a
second you're talking about a cosmic
entity not only that the Phoenix forces
omniversal what that means is there's
only one Phoenix force in the whole
multiverse and there's different avatars
of the Phoenix force in each universe
but you're basically talking about a
multiversal entity being banished by the
coven from this one particular realm in
the universe that is an insane level of
power but of course what the Phoenix
force basically abandoning thing is Jeff
lemierre's way of basically bringing
bringing things back down and simply
saying now we're gonna find a way to end
this story what the analyst does is with
his son not having the Phoenix force he
just wrecks him in no time flat Danice
of course takes his helmet back which is
kind of cool and this simply says you're
going to spend time in the god quarry
I'm gonna throw you down here but it's
cool because Thanos essentially says
look I Know Who I am I know what I'm
about I am mad Titan none will equal me
in terms of my intellect power so on and
so forth and he basically says look
you're gonna be subjected to the god
you don't know who you are you have no
idea what you're about and that's true
Thane doesn't they lived among the
Inhumans for ever and ever and ever
until Thanos shows up and then healers
at Thanos as his father but that's it he
never had a fatherly figure to teach him
anything they never understood his place
in the universe he's just been
free-floating in the universe since the
day he was born with no Direction no
ambition no drive for anything and so as
a result when he's thrown into the god
quarry what instead of being like fan
o's where he basically experiences this
illusion of maybe Thanos really wanted
to fight alongside the Avengers Thane is
going to experience nothing we just a
litany of what amounts to a series of
images in his mind with everything that
he could be it'll basically be this huge
influx of every possibility just thrown
into his mind because he doesn't know
where he's going and he has no idea what
he wants as it was cool because with him
being thrown into the god quarry he's
effectively locked in there not only
that we end up having mistress death who
of course appeals to Thanos now remember
when it comes to the character of
mistress death is just one of these
things where she's just kind of going
with whoever the biggest player in the
field is that's really it it's not
because she has to it's because she
wants to remember we talked about that
during the events of seeker wars and the
collapse of the multiverse when it comes
to mistress death she represents death
technically speaking she cannot die you
know she'll just simply await everything
that does die now something else that I
also want to point out here is the
events of the Thanos imperative because
inevitably people are gonna bring that
up they're gonna say yeah but mistress
death died and Thanos imperative that's
true but that was a different universe
version of mistress death and
technically speaking that should not
have been allowed to happen you should
not be able to kill death itself but it
has kind of happened on a couple of
occasions but their friends stories so
like Thanos imperative for example is a
fringe story the events of secret Wars -
were just so off the wall crazy that
story went off the rails so fast but
technically speaking the Beyonder did
kill mr. steth and nobody could die so I
mean in my mind mistress death should
not be able to die I guess it doesn't
mean she can't but in my mind I really
don't feel like she should be able to
but again that's just kind of my opinion
that I'm sort of filling in here but
regardless of the circumstances Thanos
basically pushes her away and says I
have no need or want for your love now
keep in mind this is something that's
been building for a while because of the
fact that Thanos was basically cursed
with immortality and he was never
allowed to Trop really die during the
events of secret Wars when Doctor Doom
it quote-unquote killed Thanos instead
he was just kind of banished to the
realm of nothingness basically this
space that exists outside of all time
and space there's nothing
there is just a giant empty void outside
of everything when all-new all-different
marvel kicked off
Thanos basically found a way to break in
to the main Marvel Universe and then all
the events have transpired accordingly
but the idea was that when Thanos was in
nothingness
he basically fell in love with the idea
of oblivion he fell up fell in love with
the idea that there was nothing there
the cold vast emptiness now whether
that's designed to basically bring in
something like this entity that we never
knew about who's like mistress death but
represents all things that just don't
exist basically oblivion we don't know
if that's the case or not we don't
simply know that Thanos has no interest
in mistress death anymore so it's kind
of bringing back classic Thanos and then
sort of tweaking it a bit now of course
mistress death herself is banished
Thanos just kind of takes off and leaves
you know champion of the universe and
star fox and nebula there and that's
really about it
but this story effectively ends on the
fact that Thanos has returned Thanos has
come back classic nah I'm nipa tenth
wildly powerful Thanos with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]